a major theme of this course is that
cities are people not buildings the real
city is the connected humanity that
inhabits skyscrapers not the skyscrapers
themselves but still the skyscrapers
matter and so does all of the built
environment which defines a city skyline
a cities buildings give it form and
beauty and they determined the city's
affordability and access to jobs
buildings have a lasting impact on
cities and a better understanding of the
built environment enables us to better
understand everything else about the
city the first question about the
physical city is just why does the city
look the way it does why do the
structures on Chicago's Lakeshore Drive
soar to the sky and why is Paris
comparatively flat why is Mumbai crowded
but short while Singapore has dispersed
high-rise dwellings why is it so easy to
find your way around New York and so
easy to get lost and sell power the
answer to why a city has a certain shape
can often lie in the answer to a second
question how do buildings impact the
experience of urban life these two
questions are so related because
buildings often come about to solve a
particular urban problem the dense
warren of streets in older european
cities were meant to enable
transportation during a pedestrian era
and they still work better for walking
than for driving the third question is
how should governments regulate urban
form is there a right answer a grid for
every city or should modern cities be a
little less monotonous is it right to
limit height or to limit sprawl the
built environment may not be the city
but Churchill was right that first we
shape our buildings thereafter they
shape us understanding both skyscrapers
and housing and slums is a crucial part
of understanding our cities
you